AC DeSantis is absolutely fabulous she
has all of that stuff so she is going to
be such a huge part of this campaign and
and I think that she will be a very big
part of this moving forward
um she's gorgeous she's intelligent this
was a um a television news woman before
so everything that he's lacking in that
department she has and I think I think
she's going to be a huge star I think
that conservatives are going to fall in
love with this woman if they have not
already yeah I think like I think not
speak kylian I think mothers are going
to fall in love with her I think just
Independents are going to follow that I
think Democrats are going to fall over